I'm not gonna go high like these guys who don't trust their own skill sets. I'm gonna go low and work in closer from there
What?
woah woo
What are you trying to do
So I've been needing to upgrade my phone for a while Nikko mentioned that we're gonna do an archery livestream my phone kind of got
Volunteered I don't exactly like the idea of my phone getting shot with an arrow
Especially because I have to go to San Francisco with Sam tonight Niko assured me he was like oh no
It's not gonna get shot because we're gonna try to shoot next to the phone
That's the goal
Hopefully I get shot right the livestream starts in 14 minutes, so I'm trying to evacuate the Titanic here
And I'm trying to like get all my voice recordings and stuff. I don't lose
10 minutes
Try not to phone hit the palm you buy everybody a burrito or you give everybody a Stephen Spock?
For the love of God
Horizontal horizontal horizontal you want horizontal. You got to go over here YouTube. You know what intern who played our tree with us
Nothing
Do not shoot the phone the phone will be on the target, it's not funny to shoot the phone
It's not goofy to shoot the phone. Don't shoot the phone. We don't go get those briefs
You get those buried yes, and bring them to us
I'm like Stevens box where so I was just one arrow at a time. We take turns after that one arrow
We're gonna start elevating the stakes, maybe two arrows three arrows four arrows and we start doing multiple arrows your first one
You'll want to be about as far away as possible in each arrow has to be consecutively closer
You're shooting a real bow and arrow safety first take your time a quick note on drawing the bow
I'm seeing a lot of this and then letting go that's not good technique
That's not good form
Take your time put your finger up guide the arrow all the way back all draw that means the arrow tip is close to your
Finger here lower your finger and then release just a nice easy
Let go just to show you here that this isn't training arrows here. We're not gonna
Puncture a hole straight through the screen is that thicker than a phone slightly thicker come on there
We go if I can't puncture the screen with one strike. I don't belong in this competition
Run right through it blew the back off that arrow will destroy the phone and probably go straight through it
Let's all pray for Nick's phone
Hey Lynn hey everybody welcome to the Sam and Nico channel youtube.com slash Sam and Nico
No, I'm not ready can't just say ready and do it
Are you ready, I think I'm ready hey
We have a really cool announcement regarding our
Corridor store with our merchandising stay tuned to the end of this video to find out what I'm talking about
wait I want to know
Now I just got done doing my fourth ever 48 hour film festival
You have 48 hours two days to make a movie from start to finish after every 48 hour film festival
You walk away
And you're like I'm never doing that again if you're a filmmaker and you want to
Sharpen your skills or just test yourself. Go do this. It's like injecting filmmaking interior your jugular
Storytelling go out and sign up get a group of friends together one person to edit one person to shoot go make something you have
To register as a team you don't want to do this by yourself at least
Five people on crew so you need to really delegate the jobs you get these people together ahead of time actors ahead of time you
Can get costumes ahead of time even locations the thing is though
They give you a randomly selected prompt that genre
character usually
Usually there's a lines that you need to include in your script get out of town or something like that so we get first shot
Off by like 12:30 way behind schedule we wanted to get our first off by 9:00
We're already behind schedule that affects morale for the crew
I didn't even have time to do a shot list you don't have time because the director hands me the script and I'm like all
Right well first scene. Let's go. Here's where the challenge comes in cuz the cinematographer
I just have to go off the top of my head with shots start with your why'd you go in for coverage?
You got any inserts you need and that's the format you have to follow because that's the most
Bare-bones way to shoot something started around 12 you didn't finish until 10:30 and no one sleeps no one sleeps
Everyone's been on set what 26 hours, but it's 10:30 and the final cuts do at 5:00, so you got seven hours
So you have to edit the whole thing it turned out to be a very rough edit
You got the footage, and they had to just put something together
I've definitely figured out some things that will help you to maximize your efficiency
And keep your crew sane while doing any sort of timed filmmaking competition
On any film set you're gonna reach that point where you're all questioning. Why am I not in bed you know like we've all dealt with that
I'm sure Carmichael you have at the same time like this is meant to be a fun thing where you're not meant to
Question everything about the universe and life itself
The point the point should be to get as close as possible
Closer than everyone else
Every tremble is a real light tremble
I didn't get closer though, but at least I didn't hit it he can someone tell me if I'm aiming at the right spot
I'm just out it's cool. I got a flight to catch
I
Had a perfect shot lined up. I'm closer I
Put a nice another hole in our door to hell round three
There's something really cool about shooting
And having it stick there
I'd never do it on purpose
But it feels pretty it feels pretty badass go again for three each one has to consecutively be closer yes first
Let me try to put in like the corner
Closest of the oh that's pretty close I got pretty close I need to target it's in the target
I don't think sometimes
You smell that smells like steaks, I'm not gonna go high like these guys who don't trust their own skill sets
I'm gonna go low and work in closer from there what?
What are you trying to do
Your life man greatest moment of your life better than you being married
Wow
Technically closer guys, so this is not barrel. Why is it still here sigh because Nick embedded it into the metal door alright?
Closer than that arrow
Four arrows in from the outside of a giant target with a tiny phone. That's not real estates real stakes
Is it as close as you can't without hitting it closest person wins the hambone jar or free burritos from everybody for life?
It's really refreshing because you don't have time to procrastinate and that's like really freeing
Probably the most broad thing because it affects everything else it starts with the writing for the love of God start with a simple
Compact yet hard-hitting idea a couple locations at most couple characters and give yourself the time to do it
Well you want to aim for like around six pages
That's probably doable on 12 hours simple idea great execution if you go over you know four takes then slow down there Scorsese
You're always gonna be on the clock. It's always gonna feel stressful. No matter
What even if you have this simple idea should you have VFX probably don't have time if you want to?
Go for it it requires having your VFX artists on standby waiting for the footage to come in don't underestimate the power of your
post-production in this process because even if things go janky onset you usually can tweak them in some way in post if you don't have
time and post you're stuck with that jank and
Dobby winds get them out of there try to only shoot for twelve hours after that your crew is gonna start getting really grumpy
But if you can get your editor all the footage by 12:00 midnight that is the ideal thing because that means that the editor has
All night and all of Sunday up until the drop off to give that edit some love
I think a much more efficient way than
One writer do all the writing ahead of time and then hand it off to the crew is to get everyone in on the writing
Process get a writers room
There's something to be said about people who are on the production
Collaborating on the idea for the script when you get to set there's more familiarity with the material people feel a little bit more
Inspired by the project rather than the handed something make this a reality it gives everyone from different departments their chance to weigh in on
Logistical issues in the script as well before you start shooting my job is to light and to shoot if I had been in on
the writing process I could have weighed in with some ideas that would helped us minimize covered minimize the
Locations that we had a shoot in that would have sped the process along lastly don't take everything so
Seriously when you're doing this you got a freaking day to make a movie. It's meant to test you
It's meant to push you to your limits
There's gonna be a point where everyone's grumpy you feel like just so beaten down and tired maybe at the scene isn't going away maybe
You're behind schedule
You probably will be
Everyone else on that crew is feeling the same way
Don't assume that anyone's out to get you leave your ego at the door if you're an actor
And you have to pick up a light stand move it do it if your cinematographer
And you have to hold a boom on the side of camera while you can operate it do it
Simple idea great execution time for post-production
Also, you get to like go to a screening and stuff and see your film up on the screen and also possibly win
It's a competition of your film wins the city you represent that city and you move on to compete against other people's films that have
Competed in the same festival in other cities. I'm gonna try to get corridor to do a 48 hour film festival
I talked to Sam already. He was down. I think we could do well
Hey, you guys want to hear what the enough?
oh
We're bringing back a whole bunch of shirts and hats that were limited edition runs only
So now we're bringing them back for Black Friday on a sale you guys can finally get them if you miss it the first time
around we'll have more details next week about which shirts and hats will be available until then start saving your money because
It's gonna be great
We have put two arrows in us eight inches here
Technically closer all right what you guys wanted you're gonna feel what it's like to
Write here
This is actually a walk in I don't think it's close enough. I'm going for it, dude
I have yet to do some really close shots
You're gonna go right to the phone
am I
Oh, that's probably amber learning, that's gonna mess up the feed
And
Exit out the alert here we go Nick lower
I
Love watching the feed seeing the arrows slam into the target by the phone
Closer I did get closer
Hasn't gone yet by the way rim names Billy Little Billy yeah, right?
Aim technique freaks me out he's like
Oh
Wow, it's about like four inches between the lens so two-and-a-half inches from the phone itself
You think you pull that out of a metal door
What
This is where we go the danger on all my life
I've waited to play the gentleman's game and now it's here real stakes real challenges whoever gets closest to the phone without hitting it
Wins a memo for this here we go
You wanted to show you get to them?
This is the end result
Still on
But the screen is dead
Thanks for tuning in that was great kind of wanted to show you guys a really cool
Close shot flew too close to the Sun
It's good to close to the Sun man, but you know what you're not gonna honor it now. I know what it feels like
With an arrow man
That was your phone yeah
Go stop watching this video
Look up 48 hours film festivals
I want to see you out there if you're in Los Angeles you better be competing against us next year
Music and subscribe to hellopinkgirl 0 and Pewdiepie